and uh is that part of his uh bigger
preparation plan for the world
championship match that's coming up in a
couple of months to do more fitness to
uh yeah i mean uh for world championship
matters
it's always very important to be in good
physical shape and maybe even more so
this year because of the tighter
schedule with 14 rounds instead of 12
for the same approximate
period
so
indeed
you see sorry
is he happy that there was a change from
12 games to 14. yeah and he doesn't mind
that it's less three days he supported
that change
um what he will think about
the 14 rounds
and last three days during the match i
cannot say
and how the preparation is going in
general has it become more intense
already or is the does he still have
enough time now do you think to
kind of knuckle down
get into that he's been there before so
i assume he knows what he's doing he's
uh
he's comfortable i think with with the
plans and the progress
but
on the other end neither he nor his team
should be too comfortable i guess
there this kind of tournament takes its
place as part of the preparation because
we asked napo and he said well okay it's
part of the preparation so he's like
acting like it's important but it's not
so important right so obviously
unconsciously both players have in their
mind that okay doesn't matter what
happens here i should play well but
whatever happens i don't care especially
if something bad happens because i have
to be the sharpest in two months well
yes certainly being sharp in two months
is very important but magnus certainly
cares what happens here
and how much of a say do you have in
magnus's kind of choice of tournaments i
know he's playing in the european club
cup maybe as well next week well i joked
yesterday that i'm even deciding his
openings
and others
there's a precedent for that in the
chess world
some years back but
no really
that's not my call i'm i'm there to
support he can talk to me if he wants to
do the i'll do the administrative stuff
and
otherwise he certainly is the boss and
he's been for a long time